yeah welcome to blitz game against his
Okafor 44 from China China okay let's
play the C 6 be 60 once again i played
this quite often recently with the good
results can always mix it with some nums
Oh Indian flavor and the Dutch what's
this doesn't look too bad
yeah many ways to play now but i'd like
to have him lose the tempo but it wasn't
wasn't to be not sure maybe it was
supposed to early Bishop age three
irritates me a bit but night g5 but
maybe I can just return it's not
terrible oh well this is nice usually I
don't mind I exchange her maybe can go F
3 now hmm we've taken first this is much
clearer just to take first I'm not sure
that f3 is really good but it's
something I should have avoided yeah
he's probably thinking about that I
could just drop back it's not so
terrible I did not just take it d 6 was
really unnecessary are unnecessary
offensiveness on how do you call it hmm
night F for him night f45 this is what
he wants to do yeah
with some justification of course
ok let's go here first probably I need
to do that anyway night f4 if I go if
five you can take and play 95 ok doesn't
he doesn't do it let's prepare 85 if he
lets me play you five in our next move i
think i just have have a good center I
don't see it technical tactical draw
back off e5 ok now he wants to play see
if I so let's block this I did tend to
play five here we go yeah this looks
like good center d 5 f-5 c5 cannot be
bad really
cover some squares it takes you for hmm
Oh didn't talk about that
hmm
check
try to irritate him a bit with a 94 g5
let's let's try that it look so it looks
difficult to play for what 95
yeah 95 for bag that bag taking once
he's free i mean let's let's let's not
simplify things too much at least I'm
threatening on f3 how does he even
protected i also have before in the mix
if he play something like when g2 or
something i can go if all and maybe
we'll get a really great night on e for
that looks tricky for white before
sooo
yeah what a stupid piece him but it's
not it's not losing away anything at
least I don't see it I can take and play
nightie for though it took me quite a
while to see that should be bad and how
to continue now maybe queen hear this
this protects f5 so that night h4 isn't
a big deal and maybe I can I need to
improve the g7 night of course
95 isn't as good Queen d8 Knight f3
check here and you're busted oh okay
alright i saw i saw goes here he's of
course not busted okay but you can still
play this position
yeah I don't know what is this at least
yeah I was threatening night g5 if this
was was a good a good and not easy to
parry threat let's let's open office and
maybe g4 mmm default could be really
really terrible okay but I'm threatening
to take on c4 first this is a problem
and it's not it's not so easy it's not
so easy rookie five okay I now must take
and we'd be six this was my my idea at
least mm-hmm he doesn't have a really
good square i can go here but this looks
like a shaky shaky square here quincy
for Queen a to the knight on e4 was
simply great yeah now not everything is
in order his work on a three cannot
cannot enter the game ready so with
check him come on take it with check
yeah let's be good
Queenie to Sims Queenie to em should be
should be something white resigns yeah
he doesn't really have any anything Luke
everyone that's 92 yeah this was a bit
lucky I really I really forgot that I
thought he couldn't take on the ages was
just hallucinating here the 95 was was
just just the nonsense Amy I can't play
it probably it's not losing or something
but I thought that it would simply win
for me but this is not not right and b5
was strong yam this is the best move him
also according to computer yeah it opens
up the Queen yo here and it puts
pressure and it allow it also this now
he is completely just coordinated this
rooks don't work together this is the
problem of you have two rooks again the
Queen there looks need to cooperate play
together and it would it would be great
on d3 for example maybe in this concrete
position it doesn't matter anymore but
then the rooks would would be able to
create some threats um yeah it's just
just lost yeah thanks much for watching
of us nice game again with the c6 b6
line it's quite quite funny finding fun
is quite funny to play ok